hallo mein name ist luca es tut mir leid
dass ich schon wieder akinator aufnehmen
aber es ist wieder was total bescheuert
es passiert ihr könnt ihr euch noch an
das letzte video erinnert versuche jetzt
als letzte person diese flasche wasser
versuchen und nein es ist kein placement
für witte ich habe dort eine flasche
gezeigt ich habe ich kann übrigens die
flasche mal empfohlen
diese flasche habe ich im letzten video
gezeigt und versucht die zu suchen die
nato habe sie leider nicht gefunden
wurde sei allerdings gesagt dass auch
diese flasche von euch da ein
gespeichert wurde bin ich heute nichts
an auf die seite akinator de gegangen
und was sehe ich da mehr als heute vorne
mit dabei
balu com kraft das von trend vom 11
oktober 2015
wir übernehmen die scheiß sie einfach
mal unter den letzten zehn spielen bin
ich auch wieder auf platz 2 zusammen mit
kleine mutter und unter anderem mit
juliane flach und juden haben wir sogar
erzählt mein gott okay was passiert wenn
ich das ganze jetzt mal aktualisiere
sind wir dann okay hier immer noch balu
hier ist ist ukulele
wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an und
versuchen erst mal blut zu finden ist
eine figur die youtube berühmt geworden
kann sein dass das mittlerweile die
standard erste frage ist in der tat ja
ist sie so trägt eine figur
männerkleidung nein hat eine figur
violettes hna.de
ich habe ja bisher wirklich für jeden
scheiß haben uns zusammen namen
ausgedacht wie das hier ist uncool ihm
ein hund in tenovis balu die vittel
flasche können wir irgendwie vitello
nennen oder so und dann mach ich dir
hier auch noch irgendwie augen dran oder
sonst einer der im herbst
wir haben ein neues level erreicht und
zwar balu ist er bisher nur so virtuell
digital wisst ihr was ich gemacht habe
ich habe mir diesen hund bestellt bei
amazon für 90 euro
fucking 90 euro für blues tier das ist
ein schieber ihn nur genau in der
gleichen farbe wie balu aussieht ist
nicht genug ich das ist bald kommt in
echten schild
ökologie und wir haben alle ganz viel ja
also balu hat eigentlich kein violettes
haberl hat auch nicht viele tattoos
meine fünf einblick glaube ich in diesen
männlichen schwarzen einfach okay es
nicht weiblich ist eine figur aus
hogwarts nein ist ein figur torwart
welcher youtuber ist oder welcher
torwart ist durch youtube bekannt
gewesen
nein spielt eine figur häufig dass julio
sammelkarten stadt könnten wir
eigentlich ihn mal fragen
ich denke aber tatsächlich nein ist
deine figur ein tier ja denn für das
nintendo zu tun ja ja es ist blue und
blue wurde sogar schon gespielt haben
battle wie auch von teamkollege
eigentlich schon gespielt läuft eine der
vier beinen einkommen die wahre
identität von superman wie er ein handy
neins aus holz sie ja da hat deine figur
geraucht ich weiß nicht ich sag mal nein
trägt eine figur kurze haare ich sag mal
ja mein gott ist das ist nicht wahr
wobei die nato macht mir so viel spaß
ich sind also witzig jeden möglichen
scheiß reicht ihr neu ein und ich
versuchte ihn zu finden das ist mega
behindert okay gut ja als kolonie 40.000
mal
junge das sind einfach 44.000 leute
dessen komplettes fußballstadion einfach
nur aus reinstem interesse ich muss
jetzt mal eben kurz schauen wie oft ich
schon gespielt wurde speziell für gemein
kraft nein ich war nicht auf der long to
ja ich habe blonde haare figur bei
youtube am anfang hallo mein name ist
luca akinator kannst dass meine tonspur
gerade megawatt steuert die ganze zeit
diese weiß akinator das jetzt noch nicht
nein ich bin nicht in wichtigen geworden
ich bin ich weiß nicht ob sie verliebt
ist als ob er wirklich dieses bild
damals an luca con crafter luca filmt
okay let's play ja 86.000 mal steht
schokolade schon auf gutem weg balu hat
auch schon 7000 oder sogar wir können
jetzt schon wie viel vitello hat läuft
deine figur auf zwei beinen hatte würde
das mit musik zu tun nein sie ist auch
kein tier sie ist auch nicht männlich
die ist kleiner als ein meter
mir bringt mich jetzt grade weiter das
ist ja viel zu nah erlebt eine figuren
contractors immer er hat eine figur eine
ukulele nein hat etwas mit wasser zu tun
ja ich denke an wasser ich weiß nicht ob
ich lachen oder weinen soll das ist
einfach viel zu krank ja es war das
mittel wasser und es wurde auch schon
640 mal gespielt das sind tatsächlich
leute und versuchen mein witte wasser zu
spielen name korrigieren vorschlag für
korrekten namen
wie cello momentane ja gut damit haben
wir diesmal tatsächlich alles gefunden
wir haben mich nochmal gefunden kollege
balu und vitello hier ich könnte freunde
wartet mal ganz kurz
ich würde mal grob sagen
ich habe einfach zu viel langeweile wie
jetzt meine lieben freunde hat kohli
nämlich als freund vitello vitello ist
männlich und ist meine vittel flasche
ist jetzt keine mittel flasche mehr es
war kein placement viertel
ich habe sogar extra abgebracht zuculini
ist weiblich und ist meine ukulele und
balu ist männlich und ist mein hund und
er kommt wahrscheinlich dienstag an und
dann wird direkten video kommen mit balu
als küche und ich lasse euch jetzt in
rochester